[Música]
bienvenidos a esta nueva edición de la
cee conosur desde santiago de chile
donde analizaremos los primeros 100 días
de gobierno del presidente gabriel boric
el ex líder estudiantil consagrado como
el presidente más joven de la historia
de chile con tan solo 35 años llegó al
poder el pasado 11 de marzo su gobierno
formado por la coalición de izquierdas
frente amplio y el partido comunista
bajo el nombre aprueba dignidad es en
los últimos 30 años de chile y que ha
llegado con menos apoyos en el congreso
cuenta con tan sólo 37 de los 155
diputados y 5 de los 50 senadores
esto dificulta que se materialicen las
profundas reformas prometidas en su
campaña que supongan mejor salud
educación y pensiones entre otros
demandadas por los chilenos en las
últimas décadas y que supusieron un
grito colectivo en la revuelta de
octubre de 2019
la agenda del presidente que también
incluyen medidas de protección del medio
ambiente y de igualdad de género
reparación y no repetición de las
violaciones a derechos humanos en
dictadura y durante la revuelta de 2019
e inclusión de los pueblos indígenas se
ha visto opacada por las necesidades
actuales de los chilenos el fuerte
aumento de la delincuencia y las tasas
de homicidios según informes recientes
la escalada de la violencia en la zona
de la araucanía en el foco del conflicto
mapuche que ha llevado al presidente a
decretar a regañadientes un estado de
excepción y lado la inflexión área que
dificulta a muchos chilenos llegar a
final de mes también se cuentan entre
los sucesos ocurridos en estos primeros
100 días del gobierno del presidente
nos trasladamos hasta la universidad de
santiago para charlar con el analista
político marcelo media que nos ofrece su
visión de cómo va a la administración de
gabriel boric hasta este momento
y los primeros 100 días del gobierno y
presidente de boliche han estado
marcados por dos condiciones primero por
la cuota de respaldo parlamentario que
tiene el presidente boris y que hace que
permanentemente sea muy costoso a la
construcción de acuerdos en el congreso
el segundo problema es que el gobierno
el presente oricha ha generado altísimas
expectativas en el país y por lo tanto
tiene una demanda de eficiencia que
claramente entra en contradicción con el
tamaño de su coalición en el congreso
entonces creo que estos primeros 100
días muestran con fuerzas atención
agregaría también que los primeros
sentidas del presente de orilla han
mostrado errores no forzados de sus
ministros y ministras derivados de que
son en general liderazgos jóvenes nuevos
que no tienen gran experiencia en la
administración del estado
como ven la declaración del estado de
excepción algo lo que el presidente
boliche se mostró contrario durante su
campaña electoral ante la escalada de
violencia que se vive en el sur del país
en el centro del conflicto mapuche
en materia de restablecimiento orden
público me temo que la capacidad e
innovación de los gobiernos bastante
limitadas es cierto que un estado
decepción no resuelve los problemas de
fondo de la crisis política que existe
en la araucanía en la macro zona sur
pero que es necesario hacer un
despliegue de fuerzas militares o de
seguridad que permitan atacar aquellas
dimensiones del conflicto que no tienen
que ver con reivindicaciones políticas
sino derechamente con actos criminales
es una necesidad para cualquier gobierno
lo cierto es que el presidente gabriel
brito ha sufrido el desplome de
popularidad más importante sus primeros
meses de gobierno en la historia de la
democracia en chile según las últimas
encuestas en este caso de pulso
ciudadano su aprobación se sitúa en tan
sólo un 33% mientras que en su
desaprobación descendido del 57 al 50
por ciento en las últimas semanas pero
qué opinan de los chilenos en la calle
las cosas que están diciendo nosotros no
estamos de acuerdo ni nosotros ni mi
familia ni mi círculo más cercano yo
pienso que están equivocando muchas
cosas y no la verdad es cosa que yo no
estoy conforme a nivel nacional ha sido
muy complejo para él ya que viene desde
una
un gran estadio social entonces de
alguna manera muy complejo de poder
ocuparse de todos los de todas las áreas
sobre todo la educación la salud
hacer el dinero
ha estado pasando lo que suponíamos que
yo
los cambios son muy grandes la gente no
nos queda shakhtar
especialmente los adultos mayores
y me
piden paciencia para este nuevo gobierno
cuyo rumbo estará muy marcado por lo que
ocurra el próximo 4 de septiembre cuando
más de 15 millones de chilenos estarán
convocados a las urnas para decidir con
voto obligatorio si aprueban o no una
nueva constitución en la que estado
trabajando en el último año la
convención constitucional aunque las
impuestas dan como favorito al rechazo a
una nueva carta magna esto podría
cambiar una vez que ya se encuentra
disponible el nuevo borrador con el
texto ajustado para la ciudadanía y que
puede encontrarse incluso en los
comercios ambulantes en los barrios más
populares lo que está claro es que la
constitución de 1980 heredada de la
dictadura de augusto pinochet y que ha
supuesto el freno en diversas ocasiones
a cambios profundos haría que las
promesas que llevaron al poder a gabriel
boric fueran declaradas en muchos casos
inconstitucionales por eso los
partidarios del apruebo esperan que a
partir del 4 de septiembre comience un
nuevo gobierno de todo esto les
estaremos contando en próximas ediciones
de enlace conocido